We haven’t found any distant Earth’s as
interstellar vacation spots just yet, but
astronomers have found a distant ice giant
for those who prefer vacations in cold climates.
Hello everyone, Amy here for DNews.
There are three types of planets in our solar
system: rocky, terrestrial planets like the
Earth; massive gas giants like Jupiter and
Saturn; and ice giants like Neptune and Uranus.
All the giant planets are mostly made of hydrogen
and helium, but the ice giants contain a significant
amount of methane ice, which accounts for
their gorgeous blue hues.
And astronomers recently found the first candidate
ice giant orbiting a distant star.
The exo-ice-giant in question is orbiting
a star about two-thirds the mass of our Sun
in a binary system some 25,000 light-years
from the Earth.
And it’s not quite a dead ringer for our
own Uranus; it’s estimated to have about
four times the mass of our own ice giant.
But this exoplanet does have a Uranus-like
orbit, and it’s this fact that’s making
astronomers draw strong comparisons between
it and Uranus.
That it has a Uranus-like orbit suggests that
it could have a Uranus-like composition.
Unfortunately that’s all conjecture for
now; the planet is way too far away for us
to study its chemical composition.
But there’s still a lot this planet can
tell us.
It might help shed some light on how our own
Solar System developed.
Astronomers can’t totally explain how Neptune
and Uranus ended up so far from the Sun.
Computer models of our Solar System’s history
say that these ice giants should have formed
much closer to the Sun then migrated outwards
somehow to their current positions, possibly
because of the massive gravitational pulls
of Jupiter and Saturn.
Finding an exo-Uranus orbiting close to its
parent star might support this migration idea.
This distant ice giant might be a glimpse
into the life Uranus might have known had
that migration not occurred.
Are you guys as excited about this possible
exo-Uranus as the science world is?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below
or you can catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.